this Wednesday there is a a town hall
coming up at 7 30 p.m Eastern with you
know who
CNN will host an hour-long town hall
with wait for it Donald Trump which
centers on the guy who tried to kill
American democracy the American people
the greatest people on Earth we love
them all the transformation of CNN into
a journalistic whorehouse is now
complete wrong Trump going to CNN do you
think it is wrong for CNN to have him on
why
why would it be wrong Network president
Chris Lake not only hands Trump a free
hour of live propaganda dressed up as a
town hall I find it very hard to defend
the choice to give him a live platform
no matter how it is dressed up he's
running for president he's ahead in all
the Republican polls why wouldn't you
have them on sorry to keep you waiting
complicated business Wednesday at 7 30
PM Eastern CNN's presidential town hall
and the Crowder live stream guests in
drinking game rules to follow
[Music]
the louder with Crowder is
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
really quickly tomorrow there is no show
in the morning because we will be live
streaming the presidential Town Hall
live streaming the live stream from CNN
so there starts at 8 pm Eastern hour
starts half an hour beforehand to kind
of give you some context to pregame
there will be drinking game rules it'll
be guests there will be a promo code all
of the rules to follow and we'll be fact
checking the fact Checkers because I
mean things there's probably going to be
some leading questions so that's
tomorrow at uh 7 30 Eastern are you a
fan of sedition yes yes
uh and we'll also get to the deposition
of Donald some new footage that's
hilarious so so much to talk about today
look yesterday was a little bit heavy
today's going to be a fun show yeah we
also have some information that's that's
I should say curious regarding the Allen
shooter uh we have more information now
and the more information that comes out
the more you don't believe said
information because the purveyors of
information are CIA plants
I kind of just gave away I spoiled the
segment sorry but there's more to it
than that essentially we'll also be
discussing some recent polls look people
have been talking about the polls polls
don't necessarily mean a whole lot but
the trend is kind of surprising and
here's the thing both Donald Trump and
DeSantis in the recent ABC wapopo would
beat Biden the reason why those subpoles
are kind of what tell you uh the most
important part of the story and there's
a real silver lining look what you are
doing is working
every culture first right everything is
Downstream or Upstream I never really
know the term Downstream Downstream from
but then some people say it's Upstream
because it would be fun you can't pee
Upstream
well or simple logic I don't know I have
no idea I think you can the key is to
Arc so again if you're black yeah
if that doesn't even make sense it
doesn't even make sense the size
wouldn't affect the direction that's
just geometry it's not about girth this
little girl is also geometry and the
point is I haven't done trigonometry
since you know I don't know when I don't
think I've ever done trigonometry no I
can spell boobs on my uh graphic
calculator though so that was fun 200
well spent remember
yeah they're like 30 cents now so
everything you're doing smash the rumble
if you're watching on YouTube head on
over to rumble uh what you are doing is
working the views of Americans are
changing on the transgender issue and I
mean pulling away
in a by a significant margin so
sometimes people say nothing is going
well no no there's a huge difference
between what is happening in this White
House in administration and what is
happening with the American people on
the ground it really is uh it's
heartening to see so we'll be talking
about that so I bring you Tidings of
great joy and if you are watching today
on YouTube and you hear and see this at
any point
that means head on over to rumble we're
not going to self-censor Gerald number
two he looks like death warmed over
because he's sick
I merely have the sniffles my friend
is that what you call when you coughed
up a lung yeah pretty much I mean I
almost passed out during run through but
I'm fine yeah
how are you sir it's that red tide I'm
good you sound a little roomy to me I
don't know because we have two
microphones with the Hodge twins oh yes
I don't know my headphones are off I
have the ear blockage too I need a sick
one I'm looking forward to tomorrow's
life we haven't done a big live stream
like that in a while I know it'll be fun
I mean the last one we did was the Trump
thing but that was that was a little bit
more just kind of waiting around for
something to happen this is right it's
gonna be like no it was a brag Trump
being a you know a rain the last one
before that was January 6th yeah which
was canceled because of the storm so we
did it anyway they were canceled because
of a store there by the way they're in
DC when they hold these hearings not
sure if you knew that and a storm hit
Florida yeah
so you guys uh well we put in a poll out
there if you really don't want us to do
the mega live stream tomorrow let us
know I think there's a poll on social
media uh but if we do it we can't do a
show tomorrow morning and likely not
Thursday morning because it'll be like
three hours long but there will be a
Friday show and in third chair you know
them you love them
yeah there we go we're gonna get dinged
I don't care what they wanted
would that sound like Queen Miss Daisy
that conservative twins Keith and Kevin
how are you guys doing good doing good
yeah that's one homosexual I really like
it was one bad homo yeah are y'all
really fans of Queen oh hell yeah I
thought you were kidding most black
people that's homophobic Joe yes not
really I don't think Queen is that big
in the black community is it not well
I'm kind of gay so it doesn't matter
we're not really big William never
misses an episode and he just saw a
black buff twin say some kind of gay
going oh my lord it's like a cartoon his
seat just shot through the ceiling
it's gonna pee Upstream I'll tell you
that it's a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern all right tune
in that's the best thing because
notifications don't work before we move
on to anything else
Donald Trump's depositions took place
last Friday
and they're everything this is from
November they were released so they
released last Friday it took place a
while ago but they were released last
Friday but some people have been digging
through them and uh here are some
highlights again just to put a smile on
your face
when you said in that video that Ms
leads would not be your first choice
physical looks correct just the overall
not right I look at her I see her I hear
what she says whatever you wouldn't be a
choice of mine either
under any circumstances have any
interest in you
[Music]
foreign
can you see the moment in his head raise
like I'm gonna keep doing this
I know you could present to me give me a
let's do a thought exercise okay like
improv yes and give me a circumstance
I don't know Mr Trump maybe no you're
ugly That's How It Ends yeah I wonder
what his attorney was doing he's like
shut up shut the up
just say just say no yes or I don't
remember I can't say that I remember
everything that would be a lie
[Laughter]
that's what he said when it comes to uh
when you're famous yeah yeah it was
nothing wrong with what he said at all
but every time the demonize him just
because he has a preference
what's an impractical thing I mean what
is it a fish hook maneuver
yeah that's what I mean that's just how
you grab him it's not a thing what is it
you're acting like it's the butcher from
Gangs of New York I mean I think it was
self-explanatory he was just saying you
can you can grab ladies and this is the
problem too now remember that was a big
thing that everyone everyone was
you don't think Motley Crew you don't
think definitely you don't think the
rolling stuff like this is something
famous people it's not a good thing no
and that's probably because you're a
Conservative Christian right where
you're saying okay it's not a good thing
to go around and be promiscuous and
sleep but the the truth is this was
glorified by Hollywood for for decades
and now they want to you would you would
sleep with a groupie
yes many people would yes
[Music]
like the four minutes it took about four
minutes
and actually we're also oh I forgot to
mention this we're going to be talking
about Florida they're no longer allowing
the uh the Communist Chinese party to
purchase land in the United States yeah
yeah where do you guys line up on that
you think that the communist government
of China should be able to buy land in
the United States and if you think that
a Governor's saying yeah Communists who
are hell-bent on the destruction of
America shouldn't be able to own land
here do you think that's big government
because that's the argument they're
going to use all right this brings us to
uh
since we were just sort of going the
illogical route yeah yeah uh this goes
to uh what we see now from the former
vice president at a White House
screening of this film american-born
Chinese
um former vice president but had some
problems with pronunciation A few
bilingually which brings us to this week
in Biden if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or Trump and
you ain't black I honored a group of
trailblazing artists with national
Medals of Arts and Humanities the group
included groundbreaking Asian Americans
like Vera Wang
koala
I think I pronounced it correctly she
can call me Joe bitten wait if you have
a problem figure it out with you for me
or Trump and you ain't black
[Laughter]
Worst by far I almost felt bad for him
for a second then I didn't
[Laughter]
no
he can stutter in English as well as
Chinese
and you can see the moment on his face
where he gives up mentally like the boom
goes the dynamite kid he's like uh
koala
you can call me
someone like me that's what he wants he
wants the light he's desperately he's
looking for the Muppet cane to yank his
corpse off that stage who's who's the
intern who basically made him say these
difficult names it's like don't give him
names to say say many famous people
just stumble through that right come on
come on Donald Trump would have just
like and so many look well you know your
name many people
I don't mean to say you know your name
right everyone here knows their name
because they're such a wonderful people
who all know their own names
where everybody knows your name
sometimes you let it go wherever
everybody just wanted you to know I know
his stuttering it actually reminded me
of uh this old I think we have a clip
this old Richard Pryor bit you know what
I've heard in my life was a Chinese
person that stuttered
I'll never heard of a Chinese person
stutter in my life right and this mother
was off into it
man if he were alive oh man
[Music]
thank you
comedy yeah we did we might play one of
his bits that's one of the funniest
things that I talked about from an old
comedy club I don't know if you can find
it where he had a one-act sonnet and it
was all about a racist play that was
being performed for inmates all right
[Laughter]
uh so let's get to to this uh DeSantis
and by the way hit like if you're
watching on YouTube right now head over
to rumble but hit like because it helps
the algorithm we still want to reach
people on YouTube yeah because there are
demons there now
on Monday Governor Ron DeSantis uh there
he signed now into law this legislation
Banning the and just to be clear when
people say stop Asian hate stop Chinese
hate that was racism it's not Asian
haters stop Chinese hate look no one
here hates Chinese people I do however
hate the Chinese Communist Party the
government and if you are an American
and if you care about the Chinese people
you would be well advised to hate them
also so the bill bans the Communist
Party
some people trying to frame it as though
Chinese people Chinese Americans nope
nope nope nope the Chinese communist
government from buying land in the state
of Florida
so today Florida makes it very clear we
don't want the CCP and the Sunshine
State we want to make maintain this as
the free state of Florida and that's
exactly what these bills
otherwise too he has two Asians right
there just yeah that's what I was gonna
say
yeah I know China is
two seconds
yeah that wasn't by coincidence as you
can see we have two Chinese people here
yes I crap
[Laughter]
well mate I don't want I'm just joking
but so the law just to be clear it bans
Chinese uh it it bans on for purchasing
land in Florida right so there's also
legislation like this that's being
considered in Texas just to be clear
um but by the way just let me make a
quick point the the this actually has
caveats right so if you have dual
citizenship United States and Chinese
you can still buy land right if you've
been here for a certain period of time
you can still buy land what they're
trying to do is to make sure that the
Chinese Communist party can't come in
and just buy a plan which is what they
do around the world so it stops Chinese
Nationals themselves but it doesn't stop
all China it doesn't stop any Americans
put it that way no Americans no Chinese
Americans stops of course the government
of China and of course people who could
be their proxies half of whom have slept
with Eric swallow
like I mean it's not a who's who it's a
conspiracy theory that we think they're
trying to infiltrate our government they
they slept with your representatives and
by the way nothing happened
that guy still is employed yes yeah I'd
fire interns here if I found out they
were sleeping with Chinese spies well
that's well that's fair too yeah yeah
well come on that's a little hard who
does that just popped up oh no
so
of course the media is completely
outraged right over these kinds of bills
and here is something again this is I've
told you this they'll try and turn this
against you and say well any so if you
support any legislation you're not a
conservative because that means you
support paid government no no
conservative right wing if you want to
use that term conservative
constitutionalist it doesn't mean that
we don't believe in government we
believe in a very limited legitimate
purview of government how do we find out
well good good good news is we have an
instruction manual ah yeah we have the
Constitution of the United States so
protecting us
from threats foreign and domestic that
would be a legitimate role of government
that's why none of us say we shouldn't
have a military we think there's
corruption in the military we think
there's corruption in our intelligence
communities we want to streamline it we
want it to be efficient but there is a
legitimate role for a military uh for
example regulation to make sure that
people are not being fleeced through
business through illegal means these are
legitimate roles and I believe a
legitimate role of the United States
government would be to prevent a foreign
adversary who wants to witness the
destruction of America according to
their own declarations I think that's a
legitimate rule you can comment if you
agree if you disagree if you think
that's unlibertarian in me but of course
this is the argument that the left is
using their outrage by the fact that
Communists cannot purchase land in
Florida
you know what people said that when the
Japanese took over you know Pebble Beach
they they bought Pebble Beach and they
bought 30 Rock that it was the end of
the American Century and guess what yes
we survived it you know what it's called
a free market which again Republicans
are supposed to support
free markets they're supposed to support
free enterprise with Disney with cruise
lines with small businesses like this is
I mean this is about as
overarching big government socialist
government is so stupid first off he's
so stupid and he referred to Disney and
cruise lines as small businesses now I
don't care if you're a big business good
for you so long as you're an honest
business but again it's not a free
market for American land to be purchased
through
potentially funds that have been gained
through coercion like with Communism let
me let me understand this it's socialist
big government to not allow Communist
governments to buy land in the United
States did I miss something did I is
there something I missed no I think
you're uh I think you're in the nail in
the head in fact but you know here's the
fun part we we can't buy land in China
they allow us no rights to buy land by
the way they don't even respect our
freaking IP they just take your phone
and be like well that's interesting we
have one just like it in three months
yes exactly yes
it's like why do we care what these
people think it's not it's not Chinese
citizens of the United States that we're
talking about Joe Scarborough uh former
Republican Congressman I think right at
some point we're talking about the
government we're talking about China's
Playbook around the world and apparently
you haven't done any research on what
they do they talked about Japan and by
the way a lot of people don't understand
that with the Japanese first off this is
not like 1980s Japan but if you look at
for example Harley-Davidson huge mistake
for Ronald Reagan I think it's just goes
back to the AMF days these things were
awful but unfortunately they put a bunch
of tariffs on our motorcycles going
overseas right in Japan basically they
were not they were effectively Out Of
Reach for purchase for the average
Japanese Citizen and so they were
shipping over better motorcycles like
Honda like Yamaha back then and Ronald
Reagan said to make American companies
competitive we're going to put tariffs
on it but it was a quid pro quo because
it was not in fact a free market right
exactly same thing happened with
Fujifilm they basically that's right
Fujifilm onto the American Market at
Pennies on the dollar so that they could
take out Kodak right right so it's these
are not fair business practices you
can't expect us to play the free market
game with people who don't have any
interest in playing the free market game
especially if they decide to bankrupt
American businesses through never-ending
supply of core dollars that are taken to
coercion with the communist government
right that's what China would love to do
China would love to put American
businesses out of business by using
taxpayer dollars you know at gunpoint
and say oh just drop it for pennies on
the dollar take out the business or same
thing with land how how much land is too
much when you think about the Communist
Chinese government and what their
interests are do you think they care
about you not only do they not care
about you they they want what is worse
for you just to be clear by the way you
know who we're not telling to uh not buy
land in the United States Canada yeah
there's 17 other countries that have
more land in the United States than does
China we're picking on China because of
the Chinese Communist Party the
Communists I don't want Canada to buy
land either but I don't either don't get
me wrong I'm just saying like they're
they had the shot they blew it the cause
for concern is not because it's Chinese
it's Asian they have a bigger land mass
in the United States to begin with sorry
that most of it is a is a is a a tundra
Wasteland you chose it okay we sold them
to Detroit Stephen it's fine
we didn't want that anyway it's even
worse than re-gifting yeah and exit take
it what the hell take it back whatever
by the way I don't know if you know this
the Chinese National they're not just
buying land in Florida this happens
across in it they've gone even as far
north and west as Wyoming they've
Netflix even yeah Netflix got the the
rights for the TV show about okay cool
yeah
are people listening on audio
well worth it to switch to videos yes
so a couple of fast facts China owns
about 384 000 acres of land
uh in the United States and uh well you
already buried you babe you ruined it I
was going to say guess how many acres
but the answer is zero I'm sorry
I'm not feeling well
also by the way this is something else
you can even look at immigration laws in
Mexico we have some of the most not only
relaxed not only tolerant but subsidized
policies as it relates to immigrants
coming not just illegal immigrants but
foreign Nationals coming here to the
United States and foreign governments
people don't realize in Mexico if you're
not a citizen the the level of
limitations on your rights I don't know
the exact law someone can bring it from
the control room uh you have it here
yeah so that you can't buy uh land
within 50 miles of the co or 50
kilometers of the coast Oh I thought it
was like 50 feet no no it's 50 50
kilometers they don't even allow you to
be Beach adjacent
uh they have some fantastic cartel land
that you can yes they do or within 100
kilometers of the Border I believe of an
international border which they only
have two so can you imagine if we said
so if you're Mexican here uh you're not
a natural born American you can't buy uh
property within 50 kilometers of the
beach I'm like okay you mean like the
only land I would ever want to buy him
yeah
no I'm saying in California or in
Florida imagine we didn't allow them any
anywhere near the beach can you imagine
yeah can you imagine the Lamentations
from the left view won't let them get a
beach condo no I'm not saying that we
shouldn't let them get beach condos they
can't afford it anyways oh no see that's
racist it's science but they do great
work on them so yeah they do this you
need to have your balcony outfitted very
hard working you gotta get the right one
yeah listen to this guy this is an issue
of course is here it's a national let me
know if you think it's a national
security issue you can comment below not
to mention a primary concern especially
in Florida is relevant the poorly built
Chinese amusement parks
[Applause]
cheese kids just went flying out of that
thing where they missed the second part
of that clip where there's another one
that goes flying yeah it's even more
more balanced that's right Yakuza you
saw the full clip
[Music]
foreign
I think that did that was it Disneyland
yeah I think Disneyland did it
[Music]
turns three plus ages three plus oh what
plus yeah ages three plus wait a minute
first off wouldn't it be past their
bedtime if it's after dark yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I really hope this keeps going so and
that shows that you can have it impact
look this is yeah the theme of today
okay DeSantis we just talked about that
well you elected the sentence and by the
way he's emboldened because there are a
lot of he has overwhelming support
including by the way by Hispanic voters
in his State now
this brings us to some polling here also
Bud Light we just said that was a win
for you what is happening in the
American public and I get it it's easy
to think Doom and Gloom now there might
be a point where the um I guess the
Divergence is is so Stark between the
government
and the leftist activist and that's the
entire Democratic party and the average
American that things unfortunately could
go sideways they could get ugly that's
how that happens because right now every
single poll that we have available to us
and every single sort of recent cultural
shift that you have seen it has been uh
an irrefutable rejection of
progressivism of leftism people said
come on the Bud Light thing that's too
much maybe not all Americans but enough
to affect the company uh same thing now
when you look at the polls the
presidential polls between Biden and
either of the two potential Republican
candidates Donald Trump or Rhonda santis
Biden's losing but there's more uh than
meets the iso let's show CNN not happy
about it first in the first real
snapshot if you will of President Biden
standing since his re-election
announcement voters are saying he has
real work to do and that's even among
his own party a new Washington Post ABC
News News poll found that 58 of
Democrats
that they want the party their party to
nominate someone else Biden's overall
approval rating remains underwater as
well 36 percent approval according to
the Washington Post ABC News poll that's
the lowest for any American president at
this point in their first term that's
dating back to Harry Truman so some
context here that matters this is an ABC
Washington Post poll right this is this
has been well known to have a left bias
oh of course just to be clear yes now
why do they think that uh Biden is
um so crappy now hold on a second
because I don't want jail to ruin it
like last time
only 32 percent
[Music]
foreign
say Biden is you're right mentally fit
here's why though because the next
number the next number is so in other
words the number that don't believe he's
mentally fit can we have that I want to
make sure I have that number right
because 54 percent
say that Donald Trump is mentally fit to
be president and it gets worse if you do
the physically fit enough to be
president of the United States oh really
yeah I think it's something it's
something a little bit lower for Biden I
think like yeah I know it's similar like
that and then Donald Trump is actually
he's he's thought to be more physically
fit to be president than he was I think
when he ran in 2020 I believe it he's
just gotten stronger yeah it's true it's
all those Trump nfts he just sucks
it's just anger keeps you young yeah
people say that stress causes can't I
don't agree well I think I think
seething simmering rage is a fountain of
youth yeah there you go
that's his fuel even though I'm
physically fit I could go for hours I
wouldn't with you because you're not
you're ugly so I wouldn't I would never
do I could go for days I'm like a
carpenter with love making but I wasn't
with you I wouldn't make any love to you
I wouldn't even get I wouldn't even
re-gift you love
that's so cruel so so uh again I'm
looking for that number how many people
actively answered Joe Biden is not
mentally fit correct okay we'll get that
or is mentally fit you already have the
mentally fit part it's 30 32 said
mentally the opposite okay we need the
opposite number unfit and then 54 say
that Trump is mentally fit correct so
32-54 which means a majority of fighting
voters think that he's not mentally fit
to be president here's something else
only 36 percent think that Biden is
better at handling the economy than
Donald Trump 54 said that Donald Trump
handled the economy better than Biden
now I'm not saying this poll means
everything right exactly just to be
clear this was a phone poll I don't know
who answers their phone some of them
involved landlines but
again we'll compare it to previous
Washington Post ABC uh polls in the past
here's what's also pretty important in a
general election match-up Donald Trump
and DeSantis they both beat former vice
president that's huge Trump beats him by
seven yeah DeSantis beats him by five
which by the way those are kind of
within the margin of error it means that
both of them beat Joe Biden if the
election were held today according to
this poll right but that that's actually
that's pretty important because Biden
for a while was beating Donald Trump yes
polling well by right now foreign he's a
little more popular than gout but Five
Points less popular than rectal cancer
the only thing he'd be any less popular
he'd be Keith oberman's taint that's Joe
Biden this guy right now think about
this for a second this the previous poll
by the way had Trump up by about three
points prior to this so there is a
spread that's taking place and this is
important to note uh for a couple of
reasons
I've been saying this for a long time
you've had eight years of Barack Obama
okay then he had three years of Donald
Trump all right because the last year
was screwed and by Design let's be
honest we kind of all they just didn't I
think they just officially announced the
end of the emergency or something
there's some kind of new term I don't
know what they're saying but they're
like ah you can go back out now it's
like okay great don't wait up
and now you have another you'll have
another four years of former Vice
President Biden so even if people really
really don't like Donald Trump's
personality they go well hey
three three and a half
and another four this is the first time
in our generation where there is enough
of a contrast and even if people there
actually may be some value in the fact
that the contrast is so Stark even
though Donald Trump is arguably the most
bombastic dick that we've ever had in
office he still did such a better job
than Barack Obama and his proxy former
Vice President Biden that people are
reverting back to Donald Trump in these
polls that's a very powerful message as
opposed to DeSantis who would be an
unknown now let me give you some
examples here really quickly of uh some
previous polls from uh Washington Post
in um ABC I don't know if they were
always when they merged because they
used to do separate polls now it's been
I know at least since 2016. yeah so at
this point in time
uh in the 2016 election meaning in the
primaries Hillary was leading by two
okay and then the aggregate poll because
they weren't doing the pre uh the
pre-presidential polls they didn't
really have the same kind of primary
season uh the aggregate with Washington
Post ABC same poll had Biden up by 12.
by 12. so in other words you can't say
well this is a poll like Rasmussen
people will say oh it's weighted toward
Donald Trump no again you look at the
history of this poll this is one of the
widest spreads that I think has ever
come from this poll in a national
election for any Republicans since 2016.
I could be off by a point or two but I
spent some time with it that's a big
deal and any it's anyone's game it can
change yeah but there are also some
other polls but you were about to say
something there yeah so what the poll
number right so 33 believe he is
mentally fit we had we have that what we
need is how many people so it's a pull
of one thousand six people
um so 33 of the 1006. no no I got that
[Music]
thank you
had almost no confidence in the economy
48 didn't
how much confidence do you have none
zero zero no no but maybe plot more than
none zero yeah I see it I see you
haven't I see you have a notepad there
put put that down on your notepad zero
zero you know what I'm asking the house
too everyone yeah put everyone here down
for a zero as well yeah and just so you
know how many people uh people perceive
Congress they hate Congress congress's
approval rating is typically somewhere
in the very low 30 percent silver a
president to be getting down to the
Congressional approval number yes is
insane it doesn't happen well here's
something else too as people uh will say
okay this is just this is just one poll
well now we have two and again this is a
pretty left-leaning poll so it does
matter here's something else culturally
there's a shift which I think is more
important majority of Americans say that
gender is based on your sex at Birth
just to be clear from this wapo yeah ABC
poll that's overlay D there right
66 percent
now oppose biological men competing in
High School women's sports that's up 13
points
[Music]
thank you
we were worried about this and every
every pundit on CNN and ABC and MSNBC is
saying I can't believe that the
Republicans are so worried about these
trans people they're afraid of trans
people they have no idea they're not in
touch with what America especially
according to this poll and by the way if
you take out white women I guarantee you
that number is in the 70s or 80s no no
I'm not joking no you're right though
right white man black men black women uh
and Hispanic women they all opposed yeah
they were a very very small percentage
if they support it would be biological
men and women sports it was
overwhelmingly white women who don't
compete in sports so they don't
understand the violence that comes with
the biological male beating the crap out
of you so like be nice we have to be
come on come on trophies
that's what it is so 60s think about
that that's a plus 13 points there so
you see a national election right now
which we'll get back to that but you
look at the cultural issues and this is
why we've talked about this I did there
are only two genders changed my mind I
think about seven years ago I was 27 the
first one was 2016 maybe it was 2017.
I've always said this is one of the most
important issues of our time why because
you can't always disprove
your opposition's argument all of their
arguments but if you can so irrefutably
disprove one if you can prove one to be
a lie people go all right now I'm going
to have to question everything coming
from this side and this
foreign
[Music]
Victory Thomas wins the NCAA
Championship as Alana working her way
here and by the way she is a U.S army
veteran so thank her
[Music]
just the kind of girls you want to take
home to Mommy
Mommy
that's for the novelty there you go
watch that yeah not just every WNBA team
gets one yeah yeah uh trans jet I almost
said the wrong word uh gets one
transgender person on the team or
Brittany Greiner or how about new but
someone just handed you a note oh it's
[Laughter]
one time I was passing notes with my
friend and they were so profane
so profane the teacher said I knew that
the cedar was going to read it for the
classroom I swear to you the teacher was
like I'm gonna read it for the classroom
I took it ripped it up
it's like I am not getting expelled
today
it was an apology from hoodie I had a
decision to make apologize on your own
time no
also 70 yes 70 do not want any trans
issues discussed in elementary school
hey I thought
Republicans extremist fantastic Common
Sense prevails oh
I mean that's huge listen to take those
numbers and listen to what the media say
listen to what Vice President Joe Biden
says listen to what Kamala Harris and
kgp and all of these people on the left
in Congress listen to what they say and
then look at those numbers they are
trying to desperately convince you that
you do not exist and when it doesn't Yes
the gas lighting is to an almost
clinical and legal degree in other words
70 percent of Americans say what how how
high of a percentage do you think it
would be if they actually conducted the
poll what about transitioning children
guarantee you that would be in the if
they don't want it discussed in
elementary school 80 something percent
they would say so you do not you do not
support gender affirming care in other
words the vast majority of Americans are
saying hands off our kids come on
they're saying gender affirming care and
Disney is saying after dark Pride nights
ages three and up Parker Brothers I
don't understand why a two-year-old
couldn't go off a three-year-old or
one-year-old Disney what's why three
years old is that is that some kind of
line for you
is this a random pedophiles have
standards yeah which is supposed to be
13 and up I don't know 31 and up 32
months and I'm not a month
[Music]
you have to be this tall to be molested
by one of these producers yeah how many
are you I'm this many good enough for me
and get in the back oh
it is Disney look it's disgusting by the
way smash the rumble button if you're
watching right now on Rumble and here's
something I wanted to talk about the
presidential uh issue you can tell me on
a smash ramble button this is a very
rare opportunity so culturally that
gives us some context as to why Donald
Trump and DeSantis are winning that
means that it's not just about
personality at that point that means
that it is about ideas at least right
now and again you know I understand that
this is a little bit early but it is
significant when you look at the
totality of the polls but when it comes
down to the presidential election either
one Beats Joe Biden
so you are in a position to make a
decision that you haven't had in many
recent primaries
who do you actually want to be president
yeah it's that simple in other words the
electability issue if these hold
relatively stable that's kind of out the
window in other words you don't have to
say well I like uh Donald Trump but
DeSantis may be more electable or I like
DeSantis but I think that Donald Trump
has a you know he'll probably have more
money for the campaign you in the
primary get to decide who do you want to
be president period because either one
of them beat this guy yeah that's that's
that's not often the case remember when
you had I think it was down to was it
Romney Gingrich and Santorum one point
was down to McCain and I don't remember
who else was in those Prime but these
were not candidates where you were
saying who do I want to be president
you're going all right well I think this
guy maybe has a chance of winning both
of them have a good chance at winning
and so it comes down to who you want and
I want to hear uh from all of you who
you just want to be present get rid of
the issue of electability get rid of the
the issue get rid of the analysis as to
who you think is most capable they both
are right now so in this world if both
of them could beat
Joe Biden
in this election who do you want to be
President Gerald you had some
interesting thoughts yeah so a long time
a long time ago a while back when we
were discussing I guess The Land Before
Time
what's mom coming up as oil in a galaxy
far far away
um I was on the DeSantis train because I
was worried about Donald Trump's
electability I thought all of the
baggage that he had in a general would
be very difficult to overcome yeah right
and I even made that point several times
I said I would I would vote for Donald
Trump if he was the nominee 100 and I
would have no problems to be clear I
think everyone here would vote for
either one yeah but I thought I thought
okay look if DeSantis can take the best
qualities from Trump and continue that
somewhat brashness like that disrespect
for fake kind of media and accomplish
things then I think he was a better
candidate in the general but now that
that really seems to be going away and
honestly I don't think this number gets
better for Biden I think it gets so bad
for Biden in fact that the Democrats
push somebody else into the position I
don't think that'll happen I do I'd be
willing to bet you one dollar but not
significantly more than one dollar only
one in trading places fashion I'll bet
more than one day I now I now have no
problem at all because I know that if
this poll is holding true and obviously
that you have to get to the general
election and actually see that that's
holding right assuming that it's the
most free and fair election ever it
would change it would absolutely be the
most free and fair election ever no
right yeah it would actually change my
mind it would actually change my mind
from DeSantis because I'm not interested
in who I think should be president if I
don't think they're going to win I am
interested in getting the best person
into the office and if that means it's
DeSantis then it's DeSantis but now it
looks like all bets are off and it can
be Trump and I would rather have that
you would rather have Donald Trump I
would I would rather DeSantis run
Florida for four more years and then
carry the torch for another eight as
president if that is what happens after
Trump and have 12 years of those two
guys combined well that is an important
Point too because again you have that
contrast you have Obama you have Trump
then you have Biden right whereas
DeSantis isn't unknown right and so I
think continuing that contrast which I
do think would be very fruitful look
Donald Trump made a lot of mistakes I
actually hope he cleans up he clears out
the swamp which he did not do last time
but I think seeing the contrast
economically seeing the contrast as far
as the freedom that we experience here
in the United States I do think that
there would be a real value in him being
and that would actually pave the way
more effectively for DeSantis whereas
DeSantis could do really well but people
might not in their mind go oh so it's
kind of like a continuance of trump
people didn't have short-term memories
and they say let's try something new
they go from something new to something
new but if it goes Obama
Donald Trump former Vice President Biden
Trump and he does well again I do think
you're looking at four years of descent
just paves the way he can draft in what
do you what do you what do you guys uh
who would you want if you just if you
could pick this ancestor Trump now that
they both beat Biden in general I mean I
I love DeSantis but I would feel guilty
if uh
[Music]
and his defense was she's ugly
nobody would believe you know I'm not
going to believe her no I mean she's
ugly yeah well you gotta go back in time
she probably look good go back in time
look at Hillary Clinton I would bang
that you don't put the steering wheel
lock on a 98 Oldsmobile right right
you're not worried about it you steal
the Ferrari yes I think I think I'm
booming yeah I would vote for either one
of them whoever comes through the
primary so I'm gonna vote for well but
then but in the primary in the primary
ah
I want to see them to uh debate you know
I so I don't want DeSantis bloodied for
when he runs for president because Trump
will go that's something yeah yeah
exactly that's I think the census will
hold his own what he did in Florida and
like the whole Chinese thing he's like
everything from done he's been a step
but we haven't seen him on a national
debate right and here's what he's not
ready for it it's small penis to Santa
yes
how do you respond to that now it's big
I did see it uh the sense is like all
fat and Pudgy and then here
I'm telling you it would be No Holds
Barred and I just don't want to see that
for him yeah it would be that's true you
cannot prepare for that and I do think
there would be some tricks up Donald
Trump
oh definitely like present a picture
like no what I have
here right next
to Mr Ted Cruz is dead
wow who did that he already alluded to
the he might be a child molester yeah
exactly yeah and it's like a bad
Photoshop picture right well the thing
people know if they want to vote for him
that's fine but maybe they'd feel
differently if they knew that your
father was actually Ted Bundy
isn't that right run bendy and then
everyone will be calling money
you got me yeah it's exactly it all
right
so no but I I I understand this is a
ShakeOut phase but I don't want to see I
I that's a good point Jill neither one
of them needs to be bloodied anymore
than they are at this point and I do
think the scientist has been handling
that component better than Donald Trump
Donald Trump's been pretty pretty rough
uh Trump supporters been uh calling uh
the census of Sorrows plant I know
that's that's the kind of thing this is
the kind of thing right now that you
have to fight against if you're Rod
DeSantis like you're just gonna get
punched from every single side and look
he's so far down in the primary it
doesn't make sense for him to try to run
if Trump is doing that well why are you
so upset that I said you're funded by
Sirus no one would be that upset unless
unless they were funny
what no I'm not that's what I would say
if I haven't flooded by serious I would
say
that's what I would say
what say you he's like I'm not see what
I tell you he's saying that's exactly
that's an admission of guilt folks let's
do a Scooby-Doo episode
wait right here silver lining people are
tired of the trans issues and the Gap is
getting wider sorry poor choice of words
it's the uh the winning margin is just
you know okay the point is it's weird
okay you all understand that it's weird
you want to protect your kids and either
Donald Trump or descendants hey maybe
that means that that uh Swami uh has a
chance yeah
foreign
I don't know what Donald Trump would do
to him in a debate that might be really
uncomfortable okay it would yes it would
I know we're all picturing it now right
now exactly what he would do I can't say
it just be like penis terrorists just
just completely Overlook them have a
picture of him on flight 93. who's this
oh instead of jumping out with a
parachute look at that photographic
evidence folks
he's like but I'm Indian yeah I'm I'm
not Muslim that's exactly what a Muslim
terrorist would say
he would say he's not
even though he is folks okay
so let's go to speaking of terrorists
the shooter and Allen look obviously
this is a heavy topic we covered it
yesterday but I think now um there are
some there's some uh what should I say
discrepancies and you comment below and
hit the like button share any of that
stuff that helps the algorithm but
comment if you've been following this
and it's hard to sort of parse through
what's what's real and what's not so
we've done our best here to try and
consolidate this for you and and give
you a clear picture as to
what is at the very least fundamentally
dishonest and what some motives might be
behind that so
um anyway Allen Texas the shooter uh
Mauricio Garcia we didn't meant we
mentioned his name yesterday we weren't
going to but at this point you know what
all of these shooters when the news
decides which manifestos they unearth
okay either it all has to be open or
none of it has to be open the only thing
more dangerous than a lack of Truth in
my opinion is half truths I really do
think that that can be more corrosive so
this is why we're going to try and be as
transparent as possible so Mauricio
Garcia uh some of his social media was
allegedly Unearthed and I say allegedly
because there's a lot behind this the
Texas Department of Public Safety in
charge of this investigation has yet to
hold a news conference or release
information about the shooter but WFAA
has obtained a bulletin sent to law
enforcement agencies about Garcia it
paints him as a radical saying initial
review and triage of the subject's
social media accounts revealed hundreds
of postings and images to include
writings with racially and ethnically
motivated violent extremist rhetoric
including Neo-Nazi material and material
espousing the supremacy of the white
race okay there's a lot here that
doesn't add up so first off you would
think oh social media a case of Facebook
maybe Instagram may be Fortune the posts
that they're talking about were
retrieved from the Russian social media
network uh okay and okay is short for
and by the way this is the number two
social media platform in Russia it's the
friends minister of Russia
it's Russia's Myspace it's okay is short
for old lip can we get Gary in here so
Gary's Russian
teacher get in the chair Gary give us
give us okay how is it to pronounced
okay it's short for the social media
Network it's called okay it's called and
it basically translates hold on a second
you're moving way too fast say it again
it is the most inefficient language
that's ever existed oh the class Nick
how do you say apple yeah
okay so all the classical translates to
classmates
classmates yes so this Hispanic American
was on say it one more time
classmates okay that makes sense thank
you Gary we appreciate it he has to go
call his mom it's gonna be a nine hour
phone call
so that's what was retrieved the profile
included what they say right troves of
Nazi imagery uh guns ammo pictures of
the Allen Mall including a graph showing
peak hours Temple screenshots
you know Tim Paul writers was like
sure
sorry Tim by the way Tim I don't believe
it just to be clear okay I don't think
that you've radicalized anybody Tim
um and then of course unhinged diatribs
but praising the Nashville shooter which
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense for a
Nazi white supremacist considering that
it was a trans liberal activist but
again you haven't had that Manifesto
even though now they've retrieved his
number two social media Russian platform
classmates
oh my God doesn't make any sense by the
way you only be on that site if you were
a classmate of someone in Russia that's
the whole point do you have any idea how
they would react if that guy showed up
that Hispanic American like what where
did you get lost and how did you get on
plane over here this is very that is
very detailed it's almost too intricate
that you are not lost
like you meant to come here but you're
not supposed to be here
we are all white we take nine minutes to
make a lunch order you were Brown you
didn't refresh Nazi tattoos oh yeah
nothing suspicious throw them in
with pedophiles okay so this brings us
to this week's curious coincidences
[Music]
laughs
got the Hodge twins here let me give you
let me give two black guys a couple more
reasons to not trust the cops so
by the way I just want to State that's
proof we can do good Stingers yep yep it
is yeah it is zip it we make our
decisions and we stand by them so let me
bring you to coincidence number one okay
the social media posts again the number
two social media platform of Russia they
were found they were discovered and this
is something pretty pretty interesting
by a researcher okay and Eric Toller
okay according to his own account this
is how he found the profile I found his
okay a collection
profile by searching for active profiles
with the filters of his birthday those
living in the U.S and mail about 50
results and the Hitler smiley face
Avatar made an easy pick for my first
choice of checking if it was him wow now
coincidentally Mr Toller this reporter
again coincidentally also the reporter
who discovered the source of the leaked
Pentagon documents last month wow he
then record the New York Times
to break the story just to be clear uh
this brings us to now you might just say
he's an investigative journalist right
he's really really good at finding
Pentagon information and finding
American Hispanics in the number two
Russian classmate site right when nobody
else found that it's a niche skill set I
have a very particular set of skills I
will cross-reference your Hispanic name
my Russian classmates number two in
Russia related to the New York Times
London
pretty much do nothing that's what I'll
do so
coincidence number two here the same guy
told her currently serves as the
Director of training and research at a
place called bellingcat and they Define
themselves they describe themselves I
should say as an independent research
but here's the truth Valencia has
received more than 250
000 from intelligence agencies including
a CIA shell company yeah just to be
clear funnel money they funnel money
through it which is what you would often
do
for legitimate news reporting they've
also employed at Bellinger this company
several uh former British American
intelligence agents okay so Mark uh
polymeropolis the cia's former deputy
chief in operations for Europe and
Eurasia even went out of his way to be
praising this outfit bellingcat saying I
don't want to be too dramatic but we
love this whenever we had to uh whenever
we had to talk to our liaison Partners
about it keyword there instead of trying
to have things cleared or worry about
classification issues you could just
reference their work their work meaning
bellingcat the place that employs this
man who found the Russian classmates
information of course which is now the
narrative that he was a Neo-Nazi by the
way if you're saying okay so some
intelligence agencies sent some money to
some other companies that went to this
but it's not like they received any
direct American Funding because the
founder of bellingcat in 2016 the guy's
name is Elliot Higgins he said they
never received Government funding right
until 2017 when he admitted that okay we
received Government funding
Federal Grant
so you've got a reporter who works for
an organization who also happened to
find Pentagon information an
organization that wouldn't almost like
PBS would not exist if not for money
funneled from the CIA and intelligence
agencies and directly from the federal
government happening to unearth this
information yes and by the way he found
it on the number two I know we've made a
joke the number two social media site
for a country that's not known for being
social if I gave you
like 50 guesses of country social media
sites that you could search Russia would
not even be on the list of places to go
and look no but not why would you go
like huh I'm going to the number two
platform in Russia that's where he is
exactly
I mean I probably honestly I'll be
honest I'm not an investigative
journalist though sometimes I am I'd
probably look at the number one Russia
social media platform and then move on
yeah exactly you know maybe not with
China okay no not really I don't know
Germany it would take me a while before
I get down to the to the uh the
Friendster to the Zenga of Russia it
wouldn't be the first place I would go
why did you like you chip like the
number one you're like what's the
Russian equivalent to Facebook it's
Facebook okay well I guess he's not a
Russian Facebook all right there we go I
covered my bases by the way he had no
interactions uh at all no interaction
huh
these generic photos were uploaded were
like um look this could be true but it's
just a curious well we'll continue and
you guys let us know you know comment
below we crowdsource us if there are
more coincidences that we miss I'm gonna
rattle through a few more here's
coincidence number uh well three as I
say in Russia
I swear that's the abbreviation that's
short it's Street talk it's too long to
say three
it's just a while
so uh this was all given to the public
think about this guys
within like one day yeah one day the
public was given access to all of this
Shooter's information again assuming
that all of it is accurate I'm not even
saying
correct or dishonest I'm just assuming
that it's accurate yeah
um
this is something that's pretty
concerning we have this we have Tim pool
screenshots we even know that the
shooter was allegedly a fan of Libs of
tick tock apparently yeah and they say
that he was inspired right this is one
of the comments that he was inspired by
Libs of tick tock and apparently had
disdain for his Jewish teacher but we're
more than a month out from the Nashville
right shooting and the shooter had a
Manifesto
it's written down for it the shoot had a
Manifesto It's a yeah it's it's there
it's in English it exists yes it's
awesome
[Music]
but the reason they don't want to give
out the manifesto but they will give all
the reasons for the inspiration from the
number two Russia social media site for
this guy was again they said they didn't
want any copycats remember that
this Manifesto lets other people read it
and then somehow copycats become
involved and the main thing you were
talking about is this called mass
shooting contagion and it's when the
releases of manifestos then contribute
to the other manifestos some people even
copy and paste the manifestos into it
and it's again it's a copycat you get
people who are doing copycat uh things
they see all the attention these things
get in the media and they're mentally
unbalanced and and they they go about
this business possible motive there is a
Manifesto now I'm sure there'll be all
sorts of debate whether this Manifesto
should be made public I would hope not I
don't think uh we want to be
incentivizing any more Behavior like
this we saw with a Christchurch shooting
that Manifesto not not be published and
I think and here's the thing a sound I I
agree with that in spirit if you weren't
pulling every single reaching motivation
from the number two Russian social media
platform to try and say that we have an
epic do you not care about inspiring
other white supremacists
there's no consistency in the
application and so either all of it all
of it has to be sealed or none of it is
sealed and the public needs to know
either the public has a right to know
all of the motivations for these
shooters or none of it yeah otherwise
it's propaganda well some some of the
other things that people pointed out
that is there's confusion about the face
of the person is this really the person
one way or the other there's a lot of
debate about that the picture that we
showed yesterday versus some of the
pictures that showed up the swastika and
stuff his face isn't in that photo
that's being shown there and it also
looks like a very brand new uh kind of
thing no interactions like I said no
shares no interactions with this post
and this is the thing I read through the
post today before the show and the thing
that struck me was that there were no
slurs whatsoever in that which is not
exactly like a white supremacist who's
about ready to die by going and killing
people because you know you're gonna die
so this guy was willing to get Nazi
tattoos yeah SS tattooed on his Firearms
I better not drop the inbound on a
Russian
CIA sorry opinion that's
[Music]
the final thing that I thought was weird
is that he had a Jewish teacher he's
supposed to be anti-semitic too right
it's a white Supreme it kind of goes
hand in hand yeah sorry
you're praising Hitler I don't know if I
need to say this but that's anti-semitic
as well right right so he was basically
saying he had a Jewish teacher who was
Miss I think it was Miss White Karen or
Miss White whatever that he referred to
her as never referred to her in any way
as anti-semitic but he just made a
mistake
Jews aren't white according to uh uh
skinheads yes to White supremacists that
you would never lump Jews into the same
box that you're in and promoting if you
are a white supremacist and so good
point some of these things just don't
really add up and other people have
looked at it like doctors and said look
I've read a lot of these manifestos I've
read a lot of these writings and it
doesn't match up with something that a
sociopath would say right it seems like
it has the kind of the the flow of it
but it has none of the other things that
you would look for as kind of Hallmarks
of some of these manifestos and it's
like this this just looks too it just
and people's conspiracy well hold on a
second conspiracy theorists what about
the plot to kidnap Governor Whitmer when
well most of them turned out to be
agents when you look at the agents who
are committing crimes on January 6th
there's it's no longer entrapment
they're the ones who create they
actually commit the crimes first federal
agents like hey come on Follow the
Leader the federal agents go
[Laughter]
marching
entrapment means you can't encourage
someone to come commit a crime to cash
them these people have actively
committed crimes members of the FBI
members of the CIA to try and get other
people to commit crimes and in this case
it's a very important Point let me recap
this just to make sure I have this right
okay
and you guys please comment if you think
I'm missing something
so this Hispanic American man
who uh he was radicalized in a household
with his non-english speaking parents
yeah into being a white supremacist also
influenced by other noted white
supremacists like Tim Poole and Libs of
tick tock
had very recently freshly uh tattooed
with Nazi and SS tattoos according to
what people are claiming from what they
have gathered from the number two social
media site in Russia which confirms that
this man is a white supremacist who by
the way left a predominantly ethnic area
of Dallas to a mostly white suburb to
shoot not black people but Asians and
white people after leaving a treasure
Trove of information on said Russia's
number two social media platform even
though no one ever engaged with his
posts so all of that but still nothing
on the Nashville shooter oh it's for our
safety all right let's just buy it
wholesale curious coincidences don't you
think Hmm
[Music]
foreign
was a hate crime that lady I mean that
guy whatever the it was
targeting Christians that was a hate
crime yes they didn't want to put it out
there yeah and it's very clear because
they said it and not just once or twice
on like let's say lithuania's number
four telegram app
to like everyone they knew it was like
Hey Nashville shooter what are you doing
today just hating Christians okay that's
what they do everybody in Lithuania new
yep she actually killed I mean whatever
the it was I actually killed a
black person yep yeah I this person I
know I believe did kill some Asian
people I know some white people three
Asian people and a couple of white
people so far I don't see any
um black people who are of old Target or
immortally wounded which of course by
the way it's wrong it's horrible that
anybody was shot but it just doesn't
match up with the motive that you have
been told and uh please by the way if
you were watching right now please share
the show because we are about to
continue uh to discuss a topic that I
know nothing about but actually I guess
there's a Gerald fill me in on this
because we're going to Mud Club yeah
we'll go to Mud Club and talk more about
it but uh turns out when you wait for
more information uh especially when it
involves kind of the metoo stuff uh you
you find out that oh it's not exactly
how you were oh it's about the it's
about the bills punter the bills punter
So when you say me too you mean rape yes
you mean rape oh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
elimination uh YouTube piss off
laughs